0: 05.0 Trying to lose weight can be difficult, and while we all know a good combination of exercise
Diet is necessary, which one is more important? If you have to choose, you must be among
Gym, or diet?
There are many ways that you can burn a few hundred calories. Run for 20 minutes, an hour
From surfing, or singing your favorite song 23 times - actually we have a full dedicated video
To exotic ways of burning calories. But the point is that it takes time to burn the amount
Great calories even with great activity - not to mention the extra barrier of moving
To the gym, and then return home.
For now, compare this to the number of calories, to transport, chocolate bar - which is often
More than 200 calories. You could either walk for about an hour to burn that 200 calories, or
You could simply not eat chocolate. Which seems easier for you? How about activity
For 30 minutes every day or dispense those two cans of soda? Many doctors point out
That there is a lot of high sugar, high fat and high calorie foods that can reduce our diet,
To learn the results of weight loss faster.
Studies tend to show that diet plays a greater role in weight loss than exercise.
The 2011 meta-analysis of children found that the level of physical activity was not
The main determinant of me is to underestimate their weight. A study of 3000 adults found that reduces
Calories were linked to more diet and weight loss than exercise alone. Furthermore it,
Studies comparing industrial and developing countries indicate that the rate of physical activity
Somewhat similar between the two communities, making activity and exercise charged with increasing
Rates of obesity in the industrialized world.
Of course, the combination of diet and exercise will yield better results in the long term.
Exercise has many health benefits after weight loss, such as slowing the aging process and improving
Mental health. But in the end, if you are looking to lose weight you
Are interested to get more if you focus on your diet first